MUST SEE TV HEARINGS ON CAPITOL
HILL.
BUT THIS WOULD BE TOWARDS THE
TOP OF THE LIST.
>> THANKS.
JOINING US NOW TO REACTION TO
HER REPORT, TOM, FORMER CLINTON
ADVISOR.
AND GUYS, I WILL START WITH YOU,
GREG.
WE ARE SENDING NOW THIS GUY
MANAFORT TO JAIL CLAIMING THE --
THE JUDGE IS SAYING HE TRIED TO
TAMPER WITH WITNESSES.
WHY IS HE IN THE JAIL AND THE
REST ARE NOT?
>> THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
THE JUDGE SHOULD BLAME HERSELF.
SHE FAILED TO ISSUE A NO CONTACT
HEARD WITH REGARD TO THE
WITNESSES.
I READ THROUGH THE COURT
DOCUMENTS.
WEISSMAN AND ROBERT MUELLER'S
EVIDENCE OF THIS IS SCANT.
AND CRYPTIC.
IT'S ENOUGH TO REVOKE BAIL
BECAUSE THAT'S A LOW THRESHOLD.
BUT THEY ALSO WERE CHARGING HIM
WITH OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE IN
AN INDICTMENT.
THAT'S PREPOSTEROUS GIVEN THE
EVIDENCE.
>> YOU AND I BOTH KNOW THAT FOR
THEM TO DO THIS, THEY INDICT HIM
AGAIN.
THEY THREATEN HIM AND NOW THROW
HIM IN JAIL.
THEY MUST BE DESPERATE.
THIS IS A GUY WHO IS CHARGED
WITH A CRIME THAT OCCURRED 12
YEARS AGO THAT HALF OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE LOBBYING SHOULD
BE IN THE SAME LOCK UP WITH HIM.
WHAT DO THEY THINK HE HAS ON
TRUMP?
HE WAS ONLY WITH HIM FOR A FEW
MONTHS.
>> THEY KNOW HE HAS NOTHING ON
TRUMP.
THAT NEVER STOPPED PROSECUTORS
FROM PUTTING A DOCUMENT IN FRONT
OF SOMEBODY THAT THEY ARE
SQUEEZING AND SAY SIGN THIS.
THEY DON'T CARE THOSE
PROSECUTORS ABOUT THE RULE OF
LAW AND PERJURY.
THEY SUBBORN PERJURY BY
SQUEEZING WITNESSES AND THAT'S A
TIME.
>> TOM, THE PROSECUTOR IN ME
WOULD NOT ALLOW THAT KIND OF
THING.
THE FEDS ARE A DIFFERENT FREED
OF CATS.
YOUR TAKE WITH MANAFORT BEING IN
JAIL?
WHAT DO THEY THINK HE WILL SAY
OTHER THAN PERJURE HIMSELF?
>> AS THE ANTI-CORRUPT WATCH DOG
IN ME SUGGESTS THIS IS
RETALIATION BY THE MUELLER TEAM
FOR MANAFORT'S PUSHING BACK
AGAINST AUTHORITIES.
>> YES.
>> I THINK IT'S OVERKILL.
I THINK THE MUELLER OPERATION
RECOGNIZES THAT MANAFORT IS THE
REASON FOR BEING.
THERE IS NO MUELLER
INVESTIGATION TO SPEAK OF
WITHOUT THIS BIG MANAFORT
INDICTMENT.
MULTIPLE INDICTMENTS NOW.
YOU SHUT DOWN THE MANAFORT
INVESTIGATION.
EVERYTHING FLITTERS AWAY BECAUSE
THE TRUMP INVESTIGATION IS GOING
NOWHERE.
THERE IS NO RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
A NICE DISTRACTION FROM THE IG
REPORT THAT CONFIRMS THE MUELLER
OPERATION WAS GENERATED AS A
RESULT OF THE CROOKED FBI AGENTS
WHO HATED DONALD TRUMP AND SET
THIS THING IN NOTION AND WERE
WORKING FOR MUELLER FOR A GOOD
PERIOD OF TIME.
THE WHOLE THING IS TAINTED.
WHITEHURST SCANDAL WITH THE FBI
LABS.
THROW OUT ALL OF THE CASES.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT IS AMAZING TO
ME, TOM.
I HAVE ALWAYS GIVEN YOU CREDIT
FOR YOUR INFORMATION.
NOW WE FIND OUT WHY WAS THIS
TEXT NEVER GIVEN TO CONGRESS?
THE ONE WHERE HE SAID, WE ARE
GOING TO STOP IT.
HE WON'T BE PRESIDENT?
NO, WE WILL STOP IT.
SOMEBODY HAS TO PAY FOR NOT
GIVING THAT TO CONGRESS.
>> YOU CAN'T BLAME THE OBAMA
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FOR THAT.
IT'S THIS FBI COVERING UP ALL OF
THESE EMAILS.
THEY ARE FIGHTING EVERY SCANDAL
ISSUE THE IG HAS RAISED.
THEY HAVE NOT GIVEN US ONE TEXT
MESSAGE.
THEY ARE HOLDING BACK
INFORMATION ABOUT DOJ COLLUSION
WITH THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
THIS JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND NOT
THE OBAMA JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
MARK PENCE, AS YOU LISTEN TO
THIS, WHAT HE SAID IS THE CASE.
THIS IS THE REPUBLICAN JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
>> WELL, BUT IT'S REALLY A STATE
UNTO ITSELF.
WHAT HAPPENED HERE WITH THE
RECUSAL AND THE INDEPENDENT
COUNSEL AND ROB ROSENSTEIN THEY
ARE NOT ACCOUNTABLE TO CONGRESS
AND CAN'T BE FIRED BY THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY CREATED A GOVERNMENT OF
THEIR OWN WHICH WE THOUGHT COULD
NO LONGER HAPPENING.
MANAFORT.
WEINSTEIN IS OUT ON A MILLION
DOLLARS BAIL.
>> HARVEY WEINSTEIN.
>> RIGHT.
>> TELL ME WHAT LEAGUE IS
MANAFORT IN?
THE JUDGE HERE IS CAHOOTS WITH
THE INDEPENDENT COUNSEL TO
PRESSURE MANAFORT TO THE LIMIT
BECAUSE HE IS THE ONLY GUY
PLEADING NOT GUILTY.
>> I GOT TO TELL YOU SOMETHING,
MARK, THAT'S INTERESTING.
AS THE PUBLIC WATCHES THIS
PROCEED.
WHO WOULD THINK IF MANAFORT
TURNED ON THE PRESIDENT NOW IF
ANYTHING HE SAID WOULD HAVE ANY
TRUTH TO IT GIVEN THE FACT THEY
ARE SQUEEZING HIM.
RIGHT NOW HOROWITZ IS GOING TO
TESTIFY ON MONDAY.
HE WILL TRY TO EXPLAIN WHY IN
SPITE OF THE PREJUDICES HE
STATED AND THE REPORT AND THE
ACTIONS WERE NOT SUFFICIENT TO
CALL FOR A CRIMINAL CHARGE
AGAINST ANYONE.
>> HE NEEDS TO SAY, LOOK, I
COULD NOT PROVE THEIR BIASSED
INFLUENCED DECISIONS.
>> CORRECT.
>> I HAVE TO SHOW YOU THIS.
THIS IS PROOF.
500 PAGES OF PROOF.
>> OH, SURE.
IT'S A REPORT OF BIAS.
DID IT INFLUENCE THE DECISION TO
CLEAR HILLARY CLINTON?
I CAN'T PROVE IT TRUE.
OF COURSE HE CAN'T.
NOBODY PUTS THEIR CRIMES IN
RECT.
NOBODY CONFESSES TO HOROWITZ.WRT
NOBODY CONFESSES TO HOROWITZ.WRN
NOBODY CONFESSES TO HOROWITZ.
>> A TRIED A LOT OF MURDER CASES
WITH CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE.
THIS IS MORE THAN
CIRCUMSTANTIAL.
PEOPLE ARE DESCRIBING WHAT THEIR
STATE EVER MIND IT.
>> THE INSPECTOR GENERAL IS A
TYPICAL GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRAT.
EVERYTHING THAT HILLARY CLINTON
DID.
ALL OF THESE DECISIONS THAT THE
PROSECUTORS AND FBI MADE, THAT
FELL DOWN IN HER FAVOR AND
HELPED PROTECT HER, THEY ALL
WERE DEFENSIBLE.
HE COULD NOT SECOND GUESS THEM.
I DON'T BUY ANY OF THAT.
PEOPLE SHOULD READ THE REPORT
AGAIN.
THE CLINTON EMAILS INVESTIGATION
WAS A SHAM AND THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION WAS TAINTED BY
THIS ANTI-TRUMP BIAS.
I CAN'T BELIEVE WE ARE STILL
TALKING ABOUT A MUELLER
INVESTIGATION AFTER THERE STRZOK
SAID HIS GOAL WAS TO STOP TRUMP.
>> RIGHT.
MARK, LAST QUESTION.
WHAT HAPPENS TO JIM COMEY'S BOOK
A HIGHER LOYALTY NOW?
>> I HOPE SALES ARE CUT OFF.
THE WHOLE WAY HE ACTED HERE IN
DEFIANCE.
YOU EXPECT HIM TO BE IN DEFIANCE
NOW THAT HE IS A PRIVATE
CITIZEN.
I THOUGHT AND I WROTE A PIECE A
HIGHER DISLOYALTY.
I THINK HE BROUGHT DOWN THE FBI.
HILLARY CLINTON WAS THE WINNER
IN THIS REPORT BECAUSE THEY SAID
THE ACTIONS WERE REASONABLE.
I THINK COMEY AND THE FBI WERE
LOSERS.
THEY DIDN'T OPERATE IN A
REMOTELY PROFESSIONAL WAY.